we're going to continue our
conversations with 2022 midterm
candidates today we will be speaking
with j.r majewski who's a republican
candidate for congress hoping to
represent ohio's ninth district uh j.r
it's really great to have you on today
thanks dave good pleasure to be here sir
i appreciate it so uh so why are you
running what what led you to run
well um you know i've lived in the ninth
district for
um
pretty much my entire life born and
raised here and um
i've become
more and more active in the community
and uh you know i decided that uh with
with marcy kapter being at you know
having served office for 40 years
and
um you know just the way the country i
think is going at this time i think that
uh
it's time it was time for someone like
me to jump in the race and someone
that's actually born here and and
that was raised here understands the
district you know grew up
and uh lived through all the trials and
tribulations that the district has to
offer and someone who served the country
i think that uh you know i could be a uh
an asset to all the people that live
here
what things would you say are not going
in the right direction in the district
um representation i think is is is one
thing um you know if you if you
go across district 9 and talk to folks
regardless of their political
affiliation um
they find uh many people don't even know
who marcy is and you know having been in
office for 40 years i find that
troubling um
you know this secondly we're we're
becoming more and more of a polarized
nation and uh i think getting back into
the practice of engaging in healthy
political discourse is missing and uh
you know that's something that that i've
always been about and um you know i i
really think that
we need someone to bring that behavior
and that mindset
into uh the leadership position of
of representative for for this district
one of the things that your i believe
it's your communications director it was
your communications contact that we were
in touch with said
was that
you're a constitutional warrior and you
want to take the country back can you
talk about who do you want to take it
back from
i think it needs to be taken back from
the establishment from
from those that were elected by the
people uh to fulfill you know various
roles of office but you know i think the
people um are
the general consensus in my opinion is
that the people feel as if the
government and our elected
representatives are
extremely indifferent from what our
expectations were when we voted them
into office can you give an example of
that in other words what would be who
would be an individual where we would
say the expectation was a
and here's b which is what they're
actually doing and we don't like it
um i would say
example a would be
marcy captor you would expect
if you made a phone call to your
representative that you would get
contacted and be contacted and responded
to within a reasonable amount of time
and um i've i've very rarely have met
anyone that uh can describe to me a
situation where they've called and
they've got a response within 72 48 48
72 hours i mean some folks do not even
get responded back to
so one of your big things would be i'm
hearing you say i think i'm hearing you
say
you would set up a system to respond to
constituents more quickly absolutely one
of my campaign commitments actually my
first one is that you know i hold a town
hall in every county within the district
that i represent at least once a quarter
when it comes to the constitutional
piece of some of the material that we
got from you are there parts of the
constitution that you believe aren't
currently being followed
yeah i think free speech is being
trampled on right now on you know from
from various outlets um
mostly from what i what i see is social
media and big tech okay um i can give
examples of that now just to be clear jr
so our audience understands
i when i said the constitution when you
say free speech am i right to understand
that you mean the first amendment to the
constitution yeah our first amendment
okay correct now the institutions you
mentioned aren't governmental
institutions and the first amendment
only applies to government so in what
way would that apply to big tech or
social media
well generally speaking i think we have
a right to free speech and
when we have institutions that um are
are meant to and intended to be a a
forum where public discourse can can
take place
and
you have
arbitrary decision makers that decide
what is good and what is bad i think
that's that that is in my opinion uh an
assault against the our first amendment
rights so let's dig into that because i
think this is such a meaty issue where
there's so much to discuss
will will you concede that the first
amendment only applies to government
like twitter has nothing that twitter's
not governed by the first amendment i
hear you saying maybe you would like it
to be but do you agree that as far as
the law is today twitter and the first
amendment are not intertwined in any way
i would say that
i'm not i wouldn't be prepared to answer
that now in the manner which i would
like i'd like to look into things a
little bit more um but i would say that
the general you know perception's
reality right and and um
at this day and age i feel as if there
is
um
again i think when i post this
something on on facebook and it gets
taken down and it's labeled as
promoting hate speech when i'm just
posting a picture of a meme of someone
there's no violence and it's just
someone's face okay i i i don't
comprehend how that is um you know
promoting violence or it's
to me that sounds like that's your
opinion about a meme but i guess so we
can establish a set of facts on which we
can then talk about this
facebook having terms of service has
nothing to do with the first amendment
to the constitution and government
abridging speech right
i can agree with that you can agree with
that so it sounds like you don't like
the way some social media companies are
enforcing terms of service is that fair
yeah that's right
in general
as a conservative
constitutional conservative do you favor
more or less business regulation
um
less i would think but it it's all it's
all circumstantial i mean you know there
has to be some regulations not all of
our businesses are automatically ethical
and principally driven so 100
100 but in general you tend to favor
letting businesses do what they want to
do if as long as it's not against the
law maybe is that fair
to a degree but i mean you know
some some uh
um
you know some some businesses
work under the auspices of uh purchase
agreements that's not necessarily the
law or labor relations agreement so i
mean you know there's just a fine line
of of being ethical and and uh you know
meeting excuse me meeting their their
responsibilities regardless of you know
where that where that responsibility
stems from 100 fair i'm with you all the
way as applied
oh yeah go ahead
i'm actually more of a libertarian
oh even so even more interesting then so
as a libertarian
would you agree that forcing a private
company like twitter or facebook to have
to publish your meme would be extremely
authoritarian regulation of businesses
i mean i can agree i can i can i can say
yes but i mean it's all it's all based
on context you know or
when when
i mean there's nothing that explicitly
limits my ability to um
post that meme because there was no
violation of their terms of services i
can sure yeah no it sounds like you
disagree with the enforcement but you're
not actually suggesting the government
force facebook to have to let you
publish it you just disagree with their
choice
right
but and i think i think the
you know the arbitration needs to be
taken out of the picture it needs to be
black and white there needs to be if
they're gonna have rules those rules
should be you know uh enforced okay fair
yeah no i i think we might disagree
about how to enforce it but i don't i
don't disagree with you in principle
um
when this is just kind of like a gut
check question that i've been asking
candidates that we talked to and
shockingly sometimes they don't they're
not able to answer who's the current
president of the united states jr
joe biden okay and is he do you think he
was elected legitimately
i think the election was stolen
personally well you do i think there
were extreme irregularities with with
the election yes in which states
um
oh man you got me on the spot
um
i know well i guess let me put it a
different way
there's no one state that
biden won that's in question that would
have flipped it to trump so i guess what
group of states might be part of it
well i mean
georgia had election
irregularities
arizona pennsylvania wisconsin um even
here in ohio we had some
okay
and when you say irregularities there's
been claims levied like for example
dead people voted people voted twice you
know all these different things somebody
there were quote massive dumps of
ballots in the middle of the night this
type of thing what specifically do you
think happened like in georgia for a
good and i mentioned georgia because
republicans oversaw that and were in
charge of the election what do you think
happened i mean personally i don't
speculate on those things what i say is
that you know where they're smoking work
there's fire okay and i believe that
congress i believe that our congress had
an obligation to
um you know put put those concerns of a
lot of american people to rest
whether they were right or wrong
uh our congressional members have an
obligation and the fact that we want you
know we we've moved forward
and um congress hasn't put those issues
to rest that is it's it's just uh
it's exacerbated the problem where we
have people on both sides of the aisle
that are that are so polarized i mean
look well help me understand putting to
rest because when i do i try to do a
fair hearing right of the claims
and we had 63 different state level
legal complaints filed all found to be
either without merit or to lack standing
and we had
a variety of different investigations
take place in different states there was
one in georgia there was one in arizona
sometimes it turns out joe biden won by
even more what would satisfy you that
would quote put it to rest as you say
um
an audit a full-on audit of the states
that that have asked for one um
if if if you know arizona claims that
they've had election irregularities and
they
are the the people there are asking for
an audit i believe that you know our
congress should allow that to move
forward but they didn't know it in
arizona and biden got even more votes
okay the cyber ninjas did the audit was
it was that audit not satisfactory
that's true that's true you're right on
that um
what about wisconsin pennsylvania
yeah i guess the question would be
if there are irregularities
why is it that no courts seem to agree
with that even when it's trump appointed
judges you know i'm trying to figure it
out for myself yeah but i mean you're
somewhat of putting a slight on its
republican this republican i'm not
looking at it in that manner i'm looking
at it from the people okay the people
are asking for i mean it's not a
partisan argument it's if the people
believe that the election was stolen
whether if it's they you know they
believe it in their hearts or you know
they're they're out surfing the internet
and they're they're they're running
rampant on on message boards right we
have an object in my opinion we have an
obligation as the government uh to to to
put those um concerns the rest and i i
if if they were put to rest people like
me i mean look i'm a very reasonable guy
yeah um i might be a trump supporter but
that doesn't mean um you know i'm doing
things that certain folks would
attribute to you know your rampant trump
trump supporters no that's why i think
this conversation is so useful so i
guess my question would be like what's
the threshold right because most people
in wisconsin don't think that it was
rigged in wisconsin or that it was
stolen there are some people that do but
it's not the majority so what should be
the threshold to trigger a multi-million
dollar audit at taxpayer expense
i think i think it all comes from uh i
mean look each state has has to maintain
their election integrity right right and
so long as
uh
each state
is satisfied and the people aren't i
mean you have thousands of people that
are screaming election fraud maybe it's
a maybe it's a round of of uh
of um uh diplomacy i don't know but no
but that's i mean that's what i'm trying
to figure out because so you've got
almost six million people in wisconsin
right
most people think the election was was
the results are the real results biden
won
if only five wisconsin wisconsinites i
don't know what the word would be if
five wisconsin residents think it was
stolen on the basis of five people
should there be a multi-million dollar
audit no no okay
what about 100
no so then i guess what i'm asking is
what is the threshold
i mean it's not you're asking me to
answer questions that i don't believe
are relevant to oh okay
i mean
that to me that's a state issue but what
i'm saying is that there's a lot of
unrest
and when we came out of of of the
um when we when we came out of our
election cycle yep right we should have
we
everyone many people knew that there was
going to be a debate president trump
laid the the i guess the um
the thought process out there he was
skeptical of the integrity of our
election okay and many other folks were
saying the same
i would have expected congress to have a
plan to recover from that regardless of
what you know the electoral college
results were right and we didn't they
didn't do that they we just moved
forward and there are a lot of people
that feel
depre they fill the platform they what
choice does congress have if there's no
actual evidence of fraud that would have
changed the results in any states i
don't i don't think congress has any
choice well there are 63 complaints and
every court says we don't see any merit
here what can congress really do you
know
um i think congress can do a lot and
they've proved that time after time they
they just didn't i mean they
investigated president trump for russian
collusion for how many years and there
come to be no evidence of that so but
hold on a second jr
there's a difference between
the investigative authority hold on a
second let's let's take that seriously
the investigative authority of the house
is very different than the very narrowly
prescribed rules for how to count
electoral votes right like did you did
you think do you agree with trump that
mike pence could have sent it back to
the states or do you agree with the
constitutional scholars that he doesn't
have that power
um
my understanding is he did have that
power
you think he did have that power yeah
what's the basis in law for that
i mean if he had uh if he had
the the support in the senate from
from uh uh senators that that didn't
believe that the ah the result but he
didn't what i'm saying is given that he
didn't have the support the support from
the senate what could pence have done
nothing okay good okay good good so it
would have required the support see a
lot of your colleagues don't agree with
that including trump himself trump
thinks pence could have unilaterally
done something but it sounds like you
and i are on the same page yeah i don't
understand it in that manner okay um you
know i and and
i don't know what what the context of
what president trump said other than you
know i so when i hear that my impression
is that trump felt as if you know he
would have had the support in the senate
and then and then would have sent the
results back but
again if if he didn't have the votes in
the senate i don't understand how he
could have done that okay i think you
and i definitely disagree with trump on
on that let's talk a little bit about
foreign policy
donald trump was different than many
previous republicans who were more
neo-conservative like george w bush in
that trump talked a lot about he's going
to keep us out of wars
as a combat veteran yourself and as a
republican what was your sense of the
kind of trumpian foreign policy idea of
wars are
bad and i'm going to keep us out of them
i mean i think it's a good idea i think
that um you know
who wants to ha who want i mean what
kind minded kind-hearted um
american wants to to be in a war i mean
you know i think wars are bad um
they're good for
they're good for the economy in some
respects but they're they're bad for
um our humanitarian efforts across the
world i mean yeah the united states
should not be engaging in in in foreign
wars i mean diplomacy should be our
go-to at all times
on that note are you pleased with joe
biden's handling of russia's invasion of
ukraine so far committing to no boots on
the ground and sticking to it as far as
we can see
um yes i mean i i don't believe that we
should be um
engaging you know in a with a military
effort there um i'm a little bit
displeased with the
uh the the the messaging that's come out
and the turnaround
um you know
talking about having a no-fly zone um
sending
military equipment i mean to me that
that
that's something that uh
i mean no one wants to see ukrainians
die but you know vladimir putin has made
it very very clear where he stands on
what he would what he would uh perceive
as as a
direct threat and
he did highlight some of those things
and
i don't think we're doing enough from a
diplomatic perspective you want to see
more diplomacy but you're happy that we
are not engaging on the ground
absolutely fair
um january 6 2021 were you in dc on that
day
yeah i was
and were you in the area of the capitol
yeah
did you go into the capitol
no absolutely not you didn't did you
breach barricades
no you didn't
what was the extent of your presence
there
um we watched uh trump's speech
uh we walked we walked on the on the
path to uh
the uh capitol building and then
um
now in in in retrospect um there were
some wind fences that were that were up
but you know we weren't aware of that by
the time we got there and uh when we did
get to the the capitol building um
within i don't know 10 minutes 15
minutes uh capitol police
started to engage the crowd and so um
everybody that i was with we just
we left you left at that point yeah
absolutely
what's your sense of there's now close
to maybe even more than 700 defendants
to different degrees for their
involvement on on that day
what's your sense of how they're being
treated by the justice system
i mean from what i understand they're
being held with um
you know the the the do
i think the timely due process that they
deserve isn't isn't being um afforded to
them from what i'm what i understand i
would like to see these things expedited
but look this is a problem that we have
across the country um you know
sometimes our courts are overloaded but
you know there's just so much
discourse out there there's so much
messaging out there that it's hard to
see through the fog but i believe that
these folks deserve a speedy trial and
uh you know many of the charges that
have been placed against them
they've well
exceeded i would say the penalties that
they would receive for those charges
having sat in jail for as long as they
have now i'd like to see these folks get
trial that's often a standard right if
your pre-trial detention exceeds the
longest possible sentence you could have
based on the charges that that's that's
a that's an issue a very big legal issue
we recently spoke with with uh this
attorney stephen donziger who was facing
a similar situation and and this
pre-trial detention is an issue that
many on the left have been talking about
for a long time my wish jr would be that
people on the right spoke more about
this issue before it applied to the
trump rioters you know because then then
i feel like we would really have a
shared basis to argue for some reform
here
yeah i mean look i'm i look at these
things with
um the most honest perspective i can and
you know one of my platform issues is
you know looking at folks that have been
um
they've suffered some type of uh i
wouldn't say abuse but um
unfairness from our justice system uh
particularly speaking we have you know
millions of people walking around this
country right now that have had made
mistakes early in life and you know
maybe have received a felony but they've
committed no crime since and their
record is up for expungement and they
don't know about it yep you know i'd
like to see i would like to see a
federal effort
that works with the states such that we
could automate the expungement of their
records because when they do find out
you know because they've been
disassociated with you know from society
and from our economy for so long they
can't afford to get back in and look i
grew up in the toughest and and most
crime-riddled
impoverished district or neighborhood in
my district so you know i got out of it
and i i become successful professionally
and so i empathize with those folks and
you know
people that want to recontribute back to
our society back to our economy i mean
if they've if they've behaved and and
and they haven't broken any laws i think
we need to be a forgiving society and we
need to stand by um the liberty that
that that we talk about so much and
we need to make it you know we need to
make the government work for us
hey i'm with you on that j.r i don't
want to keep you too much longer but a
couple other things um one of the people
sorry
i have about two more minutes okay one
of the people that endorsed you is
michael flynn and he has said in my
opinion some really crazy things lately
including that uh there that that we
should be doing coups and a lot of
really aggressive and almost sometimes
like delusional
christian dominionist sort of stuff
is that a perspective you would bring if
you were elected or is that not really
your scene
i i mean it's hard for me to answer that
i know i know i know what you're asking
for yeah but look i i value my
relationship with general flynn he's
always been a very very respectful guy
to me um i have not seen um i've not
seen or heard what you're saying so okay
you know i
i think what you see with me is what you
get i wear my cards in my sleeve i
understand the obligations that i have
you know taking this position and
becoming an elected official my job is
to represent the people
i think congress is riddled with
ideologists that are looking to you know
further pursue their self-interest
i'm a guy that's very young in my career
very successful and uh i don't need to
be a representative um you know
financially i'm i'm much more uh better
off uh continuing my my career in the
nuclear power industry but you know
again
i'm going to bring to the table
eyes ears and
the fortitude and willingness to help
everyone in my district regardless of
their political affiliation but you know
i'm not i'm i'm not going to um you know
who i choose to pursue for endorsements
i mean look i gotta win i got
i i i'm in a i'm in a contested
republican primary uh general flynn i
consider him a patriot and uh you know i
i i like general flynn so you know that
i mean as as far as the testament to his
character i i can't speak on it i can
just tell you that when i think of
general flynn i think of a guy that was
a very successful general uh in our
united states army and he's always been
kind to me and
you know i haven't heard anything
radical that i could that i could attest
to
well i think i'm reading between the
lines a little here jr and understanding
what you're saying but i'm glad to send
you some some citations
uh i i'm not trying to dodge the
question i got you no i understand the
situation you're in a contested
situation i get it i get it listen i get
it um listen you've been eminently
reasonable in our conversation and i
think this is eye-opening we've been
speaking with j.r majewski who's running
in ohio's ninth district a trump
supporter but also a guy that we can
engage with on a reasonable basis jr i
really appreciate your time thanks man i
appreciate yours and i would say to your
listeners you know there's so much
polarization out there right now
and uh you know people see me they see
the trump lawn they see the name trump
and you know look we gotta we have to
work with each other we have to talk and
you know this this this one issue line
in the sand behavior and you know
we are not as
we are americans at the end of the day
but even even even before that we're
human and you know we have to find a a a
landscape in which we can all get back
together because this this country is
going down the tubes if if we continue
on the path we're on and it's going to
take both sides of the aisle to work
together to get this done i don't know
if that's possible the way things are
going but
you know what damn it i'm going to try
so
j.r thank you so much you're welcome